raiders you've got them at 23. now
here's my question
if they finish
in the 20s and thus don't make it to the
playoffs for the fourth year of john
gruden's return four for four no
playoffs
is that enough for mark davis to make a
change or
does john gruden get a chance to go five
for five no playoffs
[Music]
mike
you know all i know is this
you gruden in three years coaching the
raiders
has six fewer wins than jack del rio had
in his three years coaching the raiders
now obviously i don't think gruden is
going to be in trouble
if they win six games this year
but
it's gonna cause mark davis to really
start thinking
and not just about uh john gruden but
about mike mayok
and you know mike mayok's draft picks
have to do better that's all there is to
it
and you know i look at this not
necessarily as absolutely joined at the
hip
but this is a this year the raiders have
to show progress
and these these uh
you know these disappointing
defensive first-round picks like cleland
furl
uh like damon arnett especially you know
they have got to start making plays this
year and they've got to start showing
that they
deserve to be top 20 picks
and it's one of the reasons like when
everybody looks at alex leatherwood this
year
and and you know and i wrote uh you know
a week ago or so that
uh i thought that the baltimore ravens
did not have uh you know the the word
was
that las vegas was worried about the
ravens jumping up to pick alex
leatherwood and so they didn't want to
trade down
and i believe that the ravens did not
even have him in the top two rounds of
this draft so again who knows what to
believe and what not to believe but
what i'm saying is mike mayok right now
has not earned the benefit of the doubt
on alex leatherwood and look for his
sake
because i really like mike mayak i hope
alex leatherwood works out but the
reason why everybody is dubious about
alex leatherwood is not just because he
was picked higher than everybody thought
that he would be picked but because of
the record
of the raiders draft choices early on
i think if they don't make the playoffs
this year it's a given that mayok is out
i think he was in more danger than
anyone realizes ending the 2020 season
gruden just wasn't sure who he would
replace him with gruden's got more time
gruden's got more equity with mark davis
because mark davis views gruden as his
buddy and it's going to take a lot for
that relationship to implode so
i i look if it was any other coach in
any other city in any other circumstance
he'd clearly be
at the top of the list of guys on the
hot seat this year but but with davis
and gruden he gets a pass for another
year and maybe more beyond
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports